on l'appelle désormais le tender de la
présidentielle élise c'est le nom de
cette application téléchargée plus d'un
million de fois un véritable carton
lancé le 2 janvier par deux étudiants
objectif réconcilier les 18 29 ans avec
les élections beaucoup de nos camarades
de nos amis des jeunes de notre
génération suivent la campagne
présidentielle avec beaucoup de distance
voire de méfiance et nombreux sont ceux
qui n'ont pas l'intention d'aller voter
on espère qu'avec élise on arrivera à
convaincre des jeunes qui étaient tentés
par l'abstention de finalement se rendre
dans les urnes en avril prochain
reprenant les codes de la célèbre
application de rencontre kinder élise
permet de faire match et les convictions
de l'utilisateur avec les propositions
des candidats à la présidentielle à la
fin vous obtenez un score d'affinités et
donc le candidat qui vous ressemble le
plus mais derrière cette application
ludique il ya surtout une base de
données très importantes sur les
utilisateurs d'après le code que j'ai pu
étudier l'application communique à ses
serveurs les données à chaque swype donc
à chaque fois que l'utilisateur indique
apprécier ou non une proposition
politique cet enregistrement est liée à
un identifiant unique pour chaque
utilisateur rattachant les informations
qu'il a partagé les données collectées
peuvent elles être revendus à un tiers
par la suite en tout cas les conditions
générales d'utilisation de l'application
non n'écarte pas la possibilité même si
elle précise bien que ces données sont
anonymisées je comprends que les
conditions générales d'utilisation fasse
débat mais pour le moment nous ne
gagnons pas un centime avec
l'application même si nous cherchons un
business model par la suite nous
n'excluons pas d'utiliser les données
pour créer des rapports sur l'opinion
politique de certaines catégories de
population que nous pourrions revendre à
des groupes de réflexion ou instituts de
sondage aucun utilisateur n'est donc
identifié individuel comme l'ont précisé
les fondateurs à la fp des propos qui ne
rassure pourtant pas tout à fait la cnil
qui va désormais vérifier si
l'application respecte bien la
réglementation sur les données sensibles
en cas de non-respect le gendarme des
données personnelles se réserve le droit
de jeu site faire usage de ses pouvoirs
répressifs